we were talking about uh your son in the
commercial break and i asked you if i
could ask about him
he is so darn cute and oh you're so
sweet
it's like
i mean he seems really like a chip off
the old block if you know what i mean
funny
and you know witty
do you see yourself in him does he have
like comedic timing because it sounds
like he does when i see him like in an
interview it's really wild i mean i i
didn't know those things are sort of you
know whether it's nature or nurture but
he has got a wicked sense of humor and
that comic timing
which is interesting because i don't
think that is really taught i think
that's innate in you i agree um i mean
he does live in my house and we joke
around a lot and all that sort of stuff
but um i think it's very interesting and
now he he's determined to be a musician
um he's currently playing trombone and
tuba in his jazz band at school which is
adorable
um and loud in my household
[Laughter]
i voluntarily got in the tuba for the
house
gotta think through my choices a little
bit clearer oh he's so funny in fact i
have a clip of him can i show it it's
like one of his first red carpet
experiences i think it's from a little
while back but yeah
who else you want to meet turn that way
see you you're so cute who else you want
to meet
i don't know just doctor who we had a
party in the limo didn't we you did yes
we got a limo for me oh limo
he's excited about a limo i think it
might have been the highlight of the
evening for him
i also heard
that when she was like how do you like
the red carpet he was like well actually
it's gold
yeah a little too clarifying literally
he's right it is it was a gold carpet it
was the it was the emmy awards and it
was for um the cast of unbreakable
commission
okay i'm wondering um if you will do a
quick round of a few um hot topic
questions with me jane okay all right
it's time for before the break
[Applause]
okay um
who is your best professional kiss
okay uh
well you never actually saw the kiss
um but
uh i would say it was probably with uh
in national lampoon's vacation because
daddy says i'm the best at it
oh my god
my fam like my life is complete
vicky just said the best line ever about
your
randy queen
oh my god thank you i'm like
i'm happy okay um what was the last lie
you told
okay well since my son is probably
watching this i try not to lie
maybe every form i've ever filled out
ever about my weight
i don't know
perfect okay and what was your last
google search
my last google search um
was looking and i can't say what exactly
but looking for birthday presents for my
son because it's his birthday in about
seven days
so yeah so looking for treats to get him
you're a good mom you're so sweet thank
you and so are you drew
um
jane krakowski i love you so
much i love you so much
is so good and so addictive as i said it
airs tuesday at 9 8 central on fox watch
it enjoy it is just so fun and you are
the greatest
[Music]
you